today I think if you ask most people
they'd be like well Dinesh is in the
mega wing and I guess I am but I came
out of the other Wing in other words if
you look at my background I mean I'm not
some guy who like you know is a plumber
right decide to run for office I mean I
came up to the mainstream of the
Republican Party my mentor was a was a
guy who was the deputy to Bill Buckley
at the National Review my early articles
were at National Review I then went to
work for policy review which is a policy
magazine I went to the Reagan White
House I worked there for two years then
I joined the American Enterprise
Institute the think tank I was there for
10 years then the Hoover institution in
Stanford so this couldn't be a more
mainstream path of the Republican
establishment the only difference is
that after that and I think actually my
my case with the Obama Administration
you know I was at an election
um you know I exceeded the campaign
Finance laws I was you know in a
confinement Center for eight months all
that experience
helped to sort of help me see a part of
America I hadn't seen before I think
that helped to shift my politics a
little bit is it also one last follow-up
is it also that if you are a republican
it's like you're a dead man walking if
you're on the Liz Cheney Camp the ASM
Adam kinzinger Kent the uh what's it do
to where's the eye patch Dan Crenshaw
Dan crunch like if you're in that camp
like you're a dead man walking so it's
like either get on board with the Maga
train or you're gonna get run over so is
it like I'm not even saying about you
but do people just kind of have to be
opportunistic and like yeah I kind of
have these principles but if I want to
win elections or get money or donations
or or even you know fulfill what my base
wants to hear I gotta get on board with
the Maga Camp well I think actually
that's
um I I'd like to Nuance that a little
bit because there's a huge difference
between let's say Liz Cheney on the one
side and then let's take Brian Kemp and
Dan Crenshaw so Dan can Crenshaw is my
congressman
um and Dan Crenshaw won by 75 percent of
the vote he won the Primary easily uh
what state is in is this is in Texas
this is in Texas a lot of Kemp is the
governor of uh of Georgia yeah and he's
running in Stacey Abrams but he's
leading by over 10 points yeah again
right so what I'm getting on here and he
entered into a big Skirmish with Trump
huge discouragement dude I mean the
whole Raphael Warnock and the situation
of the Senate was a disaster they lost
two Senate seats because of that
Skirmish that's right and I and I think
honestly there was a lot of blame to go
around by which I mean I think that the
the charges of election fraud were made
in an irresponsible way and many people
thought well if the whole process is
rigged why should I go vote and so in a
red State you have voters who don't vote
horrible that's what helped that outcome
to happen and then there was a Blame
Game to follow that who's responsible
for losing those Senate seats is it the
Brian Kemp establishment or is it Trump
and that that continued after a while so
here's what I'm getting at Liz Cheney
has basically become at least in the
view of most Republicans and operative
for the Democratic party she mainly
attacks Republicans she endorses
Democrats so she's in a whole different
she's basically become the face of the
January 6th commission and again look I
mean there are guys in January 6 who
should have not done what they did they
should not have broken those glass they
should not have they should not have
engaged in any skirmishes with the cops
but then there's a whole bunch of other
people who walk in there nobody stops
them the cops standing around they walk
in they're there for 10 minutes and now
they're in solitary confinement I mean
there's no excuse for that that that if
they were on the left that would never
have happened to them that's the key
point and that's really that's really
all we're saying about January 6th is
that there needs to be some Equity of
treatment so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]